so you get to the end of the story and
then there's a moral which I suppose is
what I get for using a condom I found in
a wooden box under a waterfall I'm Chris
waters and you're listening to gun show
radio the show that tries to keep you
alive in this beautiful treacherous land
we call home Animal Vegetable mineral
pretty much everything in key rot wants
to kill you so you've got to be ready to
kill it first now there are a lot of
weapons out there I'm sure everybody
started their own collection by now but
you don't have to go full Sherpa just to
get by care if he walks 30 miles a day
that guy's gonna have back problems you
don't want that look you really only
need to cover your three bases killing
quietly killing a lot of things that are
up in your face and blowing [ __ ]
sky-high if you can cover these three
the rest is gravy sweet tangy murderous
gravy and if you want to survive long
enough to taste it just keep it tuned
gun show radio and don't like drive your
car off a cliff or anything or do
whatever
first things first you got to build
yourself a freaky harness of dead animal
flesh so you can carry more guns start
with three parts wolf three parts tapir
and three parts honey badgers chop off
their skins reserving a snack size
portion for your wet meat satchel and
then craft your way to four weapon fun
times now it's time to fill out those
slots but why buy a gun when there are
people out there who will just give them
to you for free well because sometimes
those people well-meaning as they are
give you a crap weapon made of sticks Oh
amita thank you so much it's so rustic I
love it treat yourself to a recurve bow
a marksman site and some explosive
arrows and you've got two of your three
categories covered already killing
things quietly and blowing [ __ ] sky-high
also the setting jerks on fire and
watching them burn categories covered
but that's a bit off-topic and also just
a bit off besides everybody knows the
bow is the business we can do a whole
dig leading up soda bout the bang
Diddley bow but that ain't exactly the
title of the show now is it when it
comes to silenced guns the pickings are
slim early on unless you get up in that
you play app and cash in your u bucks
for some sweet u rewards if you've ever
linked your profile with Uplay account
then you've almost certainly got u bucks
to spare but you can have it just take
little Tuskers here on a rage stompin
rampage and you'll be most of the way
towards unlocking the ajm' 9 a sidearm
straight out of detroit by way of Far
Cry 3 Blood Dragon the silencer isn't
foolproof you might end up alerting
someone with that 3 round burst but if
you aim for the head oh so carefully
you'll be on your way to those sweet
stealthy outpost clears and the bonus xp
they come with if your silenced approach
fails or you just can't be bothered or
you find yourself beset by a pack of
wild dogs the sidearm just ain't gonna
cut it
this is panic time time you need a gun
that will just kill whatever D holes or
a-holes are up in your face hole it's
time for the a K though honestly I'd
rather eat an arrow ensure up the
fashion week with such a played-out gun
welcome to arrow in the mouth
drive-through may I take your order
please oh yeah all I want to you're
wrong boy well thank you next customer
have some self-respect and at least go
with a shotgun man the m1 33 is a solid
choice that endangers any species
decides to get danger-close you won't
get your bonus karma and extra skin like
you do when you hunt with a bow but you
also won't have to explain to subha why
you got your limbs chewed off by the
Westminster Kennel Club
it ain't that glamorous but the sexier
shot e's require a pesky little thing
called campaign missions to unlock and
who even knows if you'll survive that
long in this crazy world this is a place
where death comes from the freakin sky
and if the skies don't get you the land
death probably will stupid land did
signature weapons however generally
don't require campaign progress as
they're mostly linked to the open world
mayhem that makes Far Cry 4 so GD
awesome for the low low price of two
royal cargo trucks you too can own an
aku won't be ashamed to bring two coop
parties and no that's not a weird sex
thing or maybe it is anywho drive or fly
around the area just north of this
comma-shaped
island until you spot one then swoop in
and robble robble the vehicle takedown
is perfect for hijacking trucks while
feeling like one of the hunky dudes from
The Fast and the Furious
and once you've commandeered two cargo
trucks the warrior is yours
killing silently and killing a bunch of
stuff real quick oh yes please that just
leaves blowing [ __ ] up as our last
unfulfilled category and here's where
missions will hook you up as soon as you
get the ki raat Fashion Week quest take
it you'd think an exiled fashionista
forced to live in mountainous poverty
would be hard to please but all you got
to do is fly above the river in a
gyrocopter then shoot some gnarly fish
demons with a freaking grenade launcher
fashion is awesome and so is the m79
it's a sidearm grenade launcher that has
one mission in life to shut it down if
there are some alive things that you
don't want to be alive or some not
exploded things that you want to be
exploded the m79 is your beat FF and if
you want to make it a menage a bum
get yourself an RPG seven you can pick
one up for free by running the hunt
survival mission from the shona
training ground outpost just north of
bonaparte all I got to do is kill a
bunch of honey badgers and endure a
tastefully minimal amount of
Meem jokes once you've got these bad
boys locked and loaded everything else
is as I mentioned before great it's a
decadent spread if I've ever seen one so
get out there and Gorge yourselves dear
listeners this is Chris waters signing
off on gun show radio be sure to check
the comments for extra survival tips and
maybe just maybe we can all live long
enough to put on a diaper
slather ourselves in body paint and hang
out with monkeys because isn't that the
dream it's my dream I'll tell you that
for free just lounging around singing
dancing maybe grabbing a little snack
you know it looks gross but the monkeys
seem to love it so I say try it why not
I mean what do you have to lose maybe
you have your dignity maybe you have
your hygiene but those have already gone
out the door I mean once you've reached
this point you might as well just take a
leap go all the way
eat some monkey lights my leg